either of you foresee ever utilizing any
AI tools and music making it's going to
come to a day where you say I want to Up
Tempo beat that sounds like this
person's style that has such and such
BPM clicked all those elements sound
like everything that I like doing you
can never say never I guess when I very
first started DJing making beats and
stuff in the 80s I never would have
thought I would use a computer you know
what I mean when I was in high school
computer was an elective class that I
didn't take I mean the truth is this the
best rapper is broke the best graphic
artist is starve as a graphic artist and
as a rapper it's not that AI is going to
be better than us that should be our
concern because your goal is how to
present this to people otherwise all art
would be available for us to see but the
truth is it comes down to how it's
presented and given the opportunity to
be in front of people's faces